i was looking through your resume
and coming across like all these great
multi-camera sitcoms that you did get to
work on
yeah i i actually just happened to be
re-watching uh news radio
and i said wow yeah i did an episode of
that yeah i remember my name it was
carol
yeah i think steven roots says it a
bunch of times yeah carol
yeah i played his uh secretary yeah
i mean do you is it the situation
especially having like spent so much
time doing like guest stop
spots guest star appearances do you find
yourself like you know
at the emmy at an emmy's party and
saying you're running into someone that
you did
like you know one episode with in 1996
yes i do like that's how i approached
dave foley
you know i said do you remember me and
he said yeah i do
and uh uh who else uh i was on a party
of five
and i ran into both of those guys whose
names escaped me now because i'm more
famous
no i can't remember their names um oh
yeah if you look at my imdb
i have you know when i first came to la
i did
probably 30 guest spots on 30 completely
different shows
some of them multi-cam some of them
single cam some of them dramas
some of them procedurals i did a lot of
different stuff
is that an experience you look back on
fondly oh yes
oh and i loved it i loved every minute
of it i had this little red volkswagen
that i used to drive around town and i'd
be zipping up and down
um uh what streets that i live on
beechwood canyon and uh going to
auditions and
doing a sketch comedy at the tamarind
theater there on franklin with my
friends from chicago and
um i had a very full fast-paced life you
know it was really
really a good time i was a very happy
person it seems like a situation where
it's like it would be
almost impossible to get bored no i
wasn't at all every day had something
and you know i was doing voiceover too
so
every day i would go to i'd audition for
uh
you know a bunch of voice over spots at
my agent's office and
and then that was a social thing too i
knew everybody in the lobby and we'd go
out to lunch afterwards and i mean
i would start at like eight o'clock in
the morning and go through to
you know midnight you know especially if
i was doing a show and i wasn't tired at
all it was just energized
it sounds wonderful again in prepping
for this looking back over your career
um i ended up re-watching the fugitive
oh my gosh yes
it seems like a fun character you got to
play you got it i noticed like the lab
coat you had some buttons on it that you
got to stylize
right i didn't do that i didn't use
those buttons
oh that was that was that was the
wardrobe yeah in fact i was a little
and i didn't have enough power at least
i didn't think so to
say whether i wanted them or not and i i
kind of
resented that the wardrobe person piled
me up with those
that's fascinating yeah i mean my real
question
is you know what is it like to have
harrison ford stare into your eyes and
smile and say you beauty oh the
best the best and you know i was
uh just a theater actor in chicago and
and uh
um i i don't know how i got this part i
didn't audition for it uh
i knew the director andy davis's
assistant
and somehow i got and it was they paid
me eight thousand dollars
and that you know it's not bad so a lot
much more than i was making then
and uh i don't know how i got it but but
showing up at the first day and
meeting him it was such a big deal for
me it was the first big star i'd ever
met and he was
wonderful to me he was so lovely to me
gave me some great tips and
you know and we had to work out a scene
together because he didn't like the
writing of it he said it doesn't feel
organic and so
we went into his trailer and we shared
an umbrella
and um we worked the the dialogue out
for that
and so yeah when he called me butte that
was a pretty big thing yeah
wonderful